YUFENG GUO: Welcome to
part 2 of our episode
on using AutoML Vision.
If you missed part
1, you'll definitely
want to watch that first.
I've included a link to that
in the description below.
OK, so in part 1, we talked
about what AutoML Vision
is used for and what
the data it's expecting
should look like.
We also gathered and
prepared our training data.
Now let's see how to use
our data to train our model.
That's just as simple
as clicking Train.
I'd recommend starting with the
simple model first of the two
choices and seeing
how it performs.
After training is started,
go for a walk, grab a coffee.
It'll take a little bit of time.
And we're back.
Once training
completes, you'll get
all sorts of statistics
about your model
which you can use to
see how it performed
and whether there were
some [? images ?] that
were perhaps mislabeled or
other aspects worth correcting.
And then you can actually click
Retrain to fix those things.
In our case, since we gathered
very specific and clean data
by design, we got some
astoundingly high metrics.
However, what
really counts is how
this model performs on new
previously never before seen
data.
I took some pictures to
try to challenge the model,
see what it would return.
Let's try this picture.
It contains the bike along
with yellow and blue chairs.
OK.
So that image was recognized
as primarily the bike
but it's got a little bit of
yellow and blue chair in it
as well.
They're in the background and
far less prominently featured
in this photo, so
that makes sense.
Let's try another.
This picture is
mostly yellow chairs
but there's a couple of
blue chairs in there,
and the model thinks it's
seeing mostly yellow chairs
with a bit of blue chair.
And how about this photo
of mostly blue chairs?
Yep, that's mostly blue chairs,
and it's got a splash of table.
And interestingly, a
bit of yellow chair,
which is not expected.
So not everything is going to be
perfect with a machine learning
model, but so far,
this model's top option
has proven to be quite good.
Now finally, let's take
a look at this picture.
Very similar to the previous
one but the front chair
is now a yellow chair.
What will the model
think of that?
Wow, look at that.
The yellow chair
in the foreground
really won out big time.
It got a way higher score.
All right.
Enough playing around with
those pictures for now.
Note that this model is
already available at this stage
to be called via its REST API.
All we did was train
it but it actually
deployed it for us as well.
The service leverages Cloud
ML Engine's online prediction
capabilities to provide
an auto-scaling prediction
service that serves a customized
model, trained on our data set.
The neat part about
all of this is
that once you have your
data pipeline worked out
from raw data to
well-formed CSVs,
the process of training and
deploying machine learning
models is completely hands-free
in that you don't have to write
any code-- just click and wait.
This allows you to focus
on getting your data
in a good state and,
hands-off, the challenges
of constructing a suitable
computer vision machine
learning model to the service.
Thanks for watching
this episode of Cloud AI
Adventures, and if you enjoyed
it, hit that Like button
down below and be
sure to subscribe
to get all the latest updates
right when they come out.
Now I'm going to go and
find me some more colorful
chairs to take videos of
so I can expand my data set
for my AutoML model.